[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعد القارئ والامام صابر محمد محمود من
سفراء القران الكريم الذين تفيدهم وزاره
الاوقاف المصريه الى مناطق العالم
فمن الارياف المصريه انطلقت رحلته مع
القران الكريم ليحط الرحاله في مدينه
سانتو امارو بساو باولو البرازيليه اماما
ومدرسا لاحد ابرز مساجدها والذي يعد
ايقونه اسلاميه اسسته الجاليه اللبنانيه
المسلمه في الستينيات من القرن الماضي
الحمد لله رب العالمين رحلتي مع القران
الكريم كانت في صغري وخاصه في المرحله
الابتدائيه
ودائما كان والد يحب الازهر الشريف
فالحقني بالازهر الشريف
وكنت دائما احفظ القران وانا في المرحله
الابتدائيه لاني عندنا في العزب عزبه
العزالي هي قريه بيئه زراعيه فليس فيها من
القراء وليس فيها من الكتاتيب وليس فيها
من العلماء فكنت اذهب من هذه القريه الى
القريه التي بجواريه تسمى بقريه سيلا يوجد
بها المعاهد الازهريه ففيها المرحله
الابتدائيه الازهريه وفيها المرحله
الاعداديه الازهريه وفيها المرحله
الثانويه الازهريه فكنت اذهب صباحا الى
المعهد في المرحله الابتدائيه
واؤدي اليوم الدراسي وانتهز الفرصه بعد
انقضاء اليوم الدراسي
واعود الى الكتاب في نفس القريه بجوار
المعهد وغالبا كان الشيخ الذي يدرس لنا في
الازهر الشريف في المرحله الابتدائيه هو
الذي كان يعلمنا القران بعد اليوم الدراسي
في كتاب القريه قريه سيلا
طبعا انا بدات الحفظ مع فضيله الشيخ صوفي
حميده رحمه الله وكان شيخا مميزا في
القران الكريم هو كان يقرا ترتيلا وتجويدا
وكان دائما يعني يقلد الشيخ مصطفى اسماعيل
حفظت معه ربما ما يقرب من نصف القران
الكريم
وهذا كان في المرحله الابتدائيه ثم بعد
ذلك انتقلت من كتاب الشيخ صوفي الى كتاب
الشيخ مبروك عبد الباقي رحمه الله رحمه
واسعه وتغمده بواسع فضله ورحمته فكنت
انتهي ايضا من اليوم الدراسي من الفيلم
الماء في المرحله الابتدائيه واذهب الى
الكتاب كتاب فضيله الشيخ مبروك عبد الباقي
في المسجد الكبير في قريه سيلا فالحمد لله
رب العالمين حفظت القران الكريم في بدايه
الصف الاول من المرحله الاعداديه يعني في
عمر 14
او الخامس عشر
وانتهيت الحمد لله رب العالمين من حفظ
القران الكريم في هذه المرحله تلاوه
واحكاما
ودائما في هذه المرحله او حفظ القران
الكريم كان له اثر كبير على نفسي وعلى
حياه العلميه والدعويه
فحينما انتهيت من حفظ القران الكريم كان
له اثر كبير على نفسه
فكنت دائما احب ان احفظ القران خاصه في
فتره الصباح هي فتره مباركه كما قال صلى
الله عليه وسلم اللهم بارك لامتي في
بكورها فمن اراد البركه فعليه ان بالبكور
ان ينام مبكرا يستيقظ مبكرا فدائما كنت
اجلس اراجع القران في عزبه او قريه
العزالي كان دائما والدي يصلي الفجر وكان
الجو شديد البروده في الشتاء
فيذهب اين
ولدي صابر صلينا
الفجر اين هو فيعود يجدوني دائما اجلس في
المسجد واتحمل البرود الشديده جدا وانا
احفظ القران الكريم وكنت دائما ادندن مع
نفسي اقرا احيانا بصوت الشيخ عبد الباسط
ترتيلا وتجويدا
وللمعاصرين والقدامى
فكنت استمتع بهذه الفتره حتى ترتفع الشمس
فاصلي الضحى ثم اذهب بعد ذلك الى العمل في
البيئه الزراعيه عندنا
وكان له ايضا يعني هذه فتره الفتره التي
كنت احب ان احفظ فيها القران واذا وجدت
فرصه سانحه وانا في البيئه الزراعيه اجلس
بين
الاشجار وفي الحقول اقرا القران الكريم
بعيدا عن الضوضاء وهذا ما ينبغي ان يكون
عليه حافظ القران الكريم ان يبحث عن مكان
ليس فيه ضوضاء فيه سكينه فيه صفاء فيه
خلوه مع سبحانه وتعالى هذا ما كان يتعبد
به رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في بدايه
دعوته ما كانت هناك صلاه وما كانت هناك
وما كان هناك الصيام انما كان يتحنث
الليالي
يعني كثيره العدد في غار حراء ما هي
عبادته عباده التفكر فدائما انسان يعني
حينما يريد ان يحفظ القران ان ينتقي مكانا
فيه السكون بعيدا عن الضوضاء فالحمد لله
رب العالمين يعني في الخامسه عشر من عمري
اتقنت حفظ كتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى وغير
كثيرا في حياتي لاني القران حينما تحفظه
يقوي الذاكره وينمي عندك الفصاحه
ويعطيك يعني قوه ففعلا حينما حفظت القران
الكريم كنت احفظ اي شيء لدرجه انني كنت في
القسم الادبي حينما اقرا كتابا احفظه حتى
وانا صغير وربما اقرا اشياء لا ادرك معنا
لكن كنت احفظها واقول دائما وربك الاكرم
انت في مرحله حياه اقرا والله عز وجل
سيكرمك بالفهم بعد ذلك ففهمناها سليمان
فكنت دائما سبحان الله احفظ كثيرا لدرجه
ان انا يعني حينما التحقت بالمرحله
الاعداديه
وبعد الاعداديه كانت هناك اما ان تلتقط
بالمرحله
العلميه او بالقسم الادبي فطبعا انا الحمد
لله رب العالمين تقدم القسم الادبي لاني
كنت احبه الحفظ واميل الى المواد الشرعيه
بفضل القران الكريم
طبعا
هذه حفظ القران الكريم جعلني دائما
ام الناس في الصلاه وانا صغير فكنت في
المرحله الاعداديه اصلي بالناس الصلوات
واصلي بهم التراويح في شهر رمضان وانا في
المرحله الاعداديه
واذكر ان اول خطبه خطبتها وانا في المرحله
الاعداديه
حينما تاخر تقريبا خطيب المسجد او القريه
في يوم عيد الاضحى وكانت
رهبه كبيره عدد كثير من الناس وكنت في
المرحله الاعداديه وطلب مني والدي ان القي
خطبه العيد وكان امر الشق علي
كبير جدا لان اول مره اصعد المنبر والمنبر
له هيبته وله مكانته ولكن استعنت بالله
سبحانه وتعالى وصعدت الحمد لله رب
العالمين
وتحدثت عن فضل اليوم وتحدثت عن قصه سيدنا
ابراهيم مع ابني اسماعيل واهم اهم الدروس
والعبر وعن بر الوالدين والحمد لله كله كل
اثنى على الخطبه ومن بعدها انطلقت الحمد
لله رب العالمين
امارس مجال الدعوه ومجال الخطابه حتى انني
في المرحله
الثانويه وفي القسم
القسم الادبي كنت احب الحفظ كثيرا حتى
زملائي قالوا انت متفوق لان القران كان
مغير في حياتي لما انتهيت من حفظه اثر في
حياه العلميه كثيرا فكنت دائما ارتب الاول
على مستوى المعهد في المرحله الاعداديه
والثانويه اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هل اتى على الانسان حين من الدهر لم يكن
شيئا
مذكورا
انا خلقنا الانسان من نطفه امشاج
بتليه فجعلناه سميعا بصيرا
انا هديناه السبيل اما شاكرا
واما كفورا
انا اعتدنا للكافرين سلاسل واغلالا وسعيرا
ان الابرار يشربون من كاس
كان مزاجها كافورا
عينا يشرب بها عباد الله
يفجرونها تفجيرا يوفون
ويخافون يوما كان شره مستطيرا
ويطعمون الطعام على حبه
مسكينا
ويتيما
واسيرا
انما نطعمكم لوجه الله لا نريد منكم
جزاء ولا شكورا
انا نخاف من ربنا يوما عبوسا
قنطريرا
فوقاهم الله شر ذلك اليوم
ولقاهم نظره
وسرورا
وجزاهم بما صبروا جنه
وحريرا
متكئين فيها على
الارائك لا يرون فيها شمسا ولا زمهريرا
ودانيه عليهم ضلالها
وذللت قطوفها
تذليلا
ويطاف عليهم
بانيه
من فضه
واكواب كانت قواريرا
قوارير من فضه
[موسيقى]
قدروها تقديرا
ويسقون فيها كاسا كان مزاجها
زنجبيلا
عينا فيها تسمى
[موسيقى]
صدق الله العظيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تدرج القارئ صابر محمود في حفظه للقران
الكريم من الكتاتيب القرانيه في قريته
وصولا الى الازهر الشريف
متفوقا على اقرانه متصدرا الامامه والوعظ
في عدد من المساجد المصريه قبل نيله شرف
الاختيار من قبل وزاره الاوقاف المصريه
مبتعثا للجاليات المسلمه في البرازيل التي
حل بها مستكشفا طبيعه مجتمعها منفتحا على
احتياجات ابناء الجاليه ورغبتهم في تلقي
العلوم الشرعيه وحفظ القران الكريم
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني الحياه تغيرت
لما حفظت القران الكريم فكنت دائما ارتب
الاول في دفعتي في المرحله الاعداديه في
المرحله الثانويه لما حصلت الحمد لله على
تقدير كبير جدا في المرحله الثانويه طلب
مني والدي ان التحق بكليه القمه في القسم
الادبي لاني مجموعه كان يسمح لاي كليه في
القسم الادبي فالتحقت طبعا انا كنت لا احب
اللغات والترجمه وكنت اعلى اعلى اعلى كليه
في القسم الادبي او قمه او نسميها كليه
القمه في القسم الادبي فطلب مني والدي
بحكم انني متفوق في الدراسه ان التحق
باللغات والترجمه او الترجمه الفوريه
لكنني كنت لا احب ذلك لكن ارضاء له ولاخوه
ولاخوتي
وضحت رغبتي في هذا وانا لا احب ذلك وضعت
لغته ترجمه في اول رغباتي وانا كنت اميل
الى كليه شرعيه لانني كنت اهبل نفسي لذلك
احب الدعوه لكن تاتي الرياح بما لا تشتهي
السفن
فوجدت اني كليه اللغات ترجمه قابله يعني
تقبلتني في الكليه وكمان يعني وايضا
التحقت باعلى قسم في اللغه الترجمه هو قسم
الالماني كان هو اعلى قسم عندنا في اللغات
والترجمه وايضا سكنته المدينه الجمعيه ما
كان في اعلى من ذلك في القسم الادبي لكن
كنت الحق دائما على رئيس القسم الدكتور
منصور رحمه الله كان طيبا وكان ابا واخا
واخا رحمه الله فكنت اقول له احب ان اترك
لي اللغه الترجمه وان اذهب الى كليه شرعيه
من الكليات الشرائع التي احبها فكان يقول
له يقول لي يا بني نحن نعلمك في اللغات
والترجمه ونترك سراحك تختار الوظيفه التي
تريدها والعمل الذي تبتغيه فكنت لا افهم
هذا الكلام انما كنت دائما اريد كليه
شرعيه هذا ما كان عندي فكان دائما يطيب
خاطري واعود مره ثانيه بعد اسبوع او اثنين
لابد ان انقل الى كليه شرعيه فلما يعني
يئس مني قال لا نستطيع ان نقل الا حينما
تنتهي من السنه الاولى اما ان تنجح واما
ان ترسب في الجامعه فقدمت طلب طبعا لرئيس
الجامعه كان ساعات الفضيله الدكتور
الاستاذ الدكتور احمد الطيب طيب الله
حياته شيخ الازهر وبعد فتره وجدت ان الطلب
الحمد لله قبيل فقابلني المسؤول وقال اي
الكليات تختار قلت اختار كليه الدعوه
الاسلاميه لانها دعوه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ففعلا كتب اسمي في كليه الدعوه
الاسلاميه وانطلقت لكل دعوه الاسلاميه كان
يتبقى على الامتحان ايام قالائل في الترم
الاول في السنه الاولى فكان عندي مشقه هل
من اين اتي بالكتب المذاكره والحمد لله
وفقني الله عز وجل ورتبت السادس على
الدفعه وكان دائما كليه الدعوه الاسلاميه
تضع صور العشرين الاوائل في كليه الدعوه
الاسلاميه يعني كنموذج للتنافس الطلبه ثم
في المرحله الثانيه في والثالثه والرابعه
وفي المجموع الكلي في كليه الدعوه رتبت في
المركز السابح على الكليه في الاربع سنوات
طبعا الحمد لله يعني هم خدوا خمس معيدين
لكن انا كنت ارغب في الدعوه ولا ارغب في
العمل حتى مدرسا في جامعه الازهر فالحمد
لله يعني تخرجت في جامعه الازهر في كليه
الدعوه الاسلاميه بالقاهره ثم بعد ذلك
كانت هناك مسابقه للائمه والخطباء تسمى
بملحق 2010 انا تخرجت 2010 فكان هناك ملحق
لمسابقه الائمه والخطباء وكان من شروطه ان
يكون خريج 2010 دور مايو فالحمد لله
انطبقت علينا الشروط فقدمت في المسابقه
والحمد لله رب العالمين اجتزت الامتحان
بتفوق الحمد لله وعينت اماما وخطيبا
بوزاره الاوقاف المصريه بمديريه اوقاف
الفيوم وعملت اماما وخطيبا في قريته عزبه
العزاء للتابعه لقريه سيلا من 2011 الى
2021 حينما اتيت الى البرازيل في هذه
الفتره الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني كنت
اكون نفسي علميا وثقافيا واطلاعا وكانت
علاقتي باهل المسجد الطيبه جدا لدرجه معهم
يعني حوالي عشر سنوات كانوا يحبونني
ويقدرونني فحتى حينما اقول لهم انني
سانتقل الى مكان اخر يقولون سنذهب جميعا
الى الوزير ونطلب ان تعود مره ثانيه فقلت
خلاص الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني الداعيه
الناجح هو ناجح في المكان الذي يعيش فيه
وبين اهله وبين احبابي وبين جيرانه ما كنا
نسمع عن مسابقه الافاده انا ظلمت يعني
طيله تسع سنوات لاسمع مسابقه افاد للخارج
وما الى ذلك لان كان الاعلان كان داخلي ما
حد يسمعنا حتى جاء الدكتور مختار جمعه
بارك الله فيك فبدا يعلن عن مسابقات
للافاد وكانت المسابقه او يعني طريقه
الامتحان والاختبار تمر بثلاثه مراحل
المرحله الاولى هي مرحله اوليه تصفيات
اوليه على مستوى المديريات والمحافظه ثم
كانت المرحله الثانيه في الاختبار تسمى
بالمرحله التحريريه في مسجد النور
بالعباسيه بالقاهره فاذا اجتزت المرحله
الثانيه التحريريه انطلقت الى المرحله
النهائيه الشفويه
جمع طيب من اساتذه من اساتذه الجامعات من
جامعه الازهر يسالوننا في القران وفي
الاحكام وفي الفقه وفي السيره وفي الثقافه
العامه فالحمد لله رب العالمين وفقني لله
سبحانه وتعالى وبعد ذلك اتيت الى البرازيل
في التاسع عشر من شهر سبتمبر 2021 اول ما
اتيت الى هنا اتيت الى جاليه اسلاميه فما
كان في اختلاف كثير لاني هذا المسجد مسجد
الرحمه الذي نحن
نسجل منه الان هو مسجد يعني يجمع المعظم
الجاليه الاسلاميه والعربيه من لبنانيين
ومن كذلك السوريين ومن فلسطين ومن كافه
البلاد العربيه والاسلاميه
فما وجدتش اختلاف كثير جدا الحمد لله يعني
احضر الخطبه
اقراها باللغه العربيه يعني لما اتيت الى
هنا ممكن اكون الخلاف بس في طريقه تحضير
الخطب والدروس
فوجدت اني لابد من تحضير الخطبه جيدا ومن
يوم الثلاثاء
اقصى مده يوم الاربعاء ثم ارسلها للمترجم
الاستاذ سمير الحايك حفظه الله ورعاه ربنا
يحفظه يقوم بترجمه الخطبه في هذه الفتره
ويرسلها يوم الجمعه واقوم بالقاء الخطبه
باللغه العربيه ثم انزل من على المنبر وهو
يقوم المترجم بالقائها باللغه البرازيليه
اللغه البرتغاليه فوجدت هنا لابد من اللغه
لانه ربما الذين يجلسون امامك بنسبه 80%
لا يفهمون اللغه العربيه
وعشرين في الميه هم الذين يفهمونها وربما
كمان لا يحسنون فهمها
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم
استقاموا تتنزل
تتنزل عليهم
الملائكه الا تخافوا ولا تحزنوا
وابشروا بالجنه التي كنتم توعدون نحن اولي
في الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره
ولكم فيها ما
تشتهين
انفسكم ولكم فيها ما تدعون
نزلا من غفور رحيم
ومن احسن قولا
ممن
دعائه الى الله وعمل صالحا وقال
انني من المسلمين
ولا تستوي الحسنه ولا السيئه
ادفع بالتي هي احسن فاذا الذي بينك وبينه
عداوه
[موسيقى]
كانه ولي حميم
وما يلقاها
الا الذين صبروا وما يلقاها
لا ذو حظ عظيم
واما
ينزغنك من الشيطان
نزغ فاستعذ بالله
انه هو
السميع العليم
[موسيقى]
صدق الله العظيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات